Shure:  好巧啊你们也在
Shure: What a coincidence, you're here too!
Katrina:  hello
Katrina: Hello
Shure:  哈喽哈喽
Shure: Hello, hello
Lucia: 真是意想不到啊
Lucia: This is really unexpected
Shure:  对不起对不起
Shure: Sorry, sorry
Jake:说明北京人人都有这个眼镜
Jake: It means everyone in Beijing has these glasses
Tasha: 我们居然能在这里偶遇
Tasha: We actually bumped into each other here
Jake:日常情况给他们也戴一个
Jake: As usual, let's give them a pair too
Shure:  白塔在北京的普及率好高
Shure: White pagodas are so common in Beijing
Katrina:  我们这个卡进来吧
Katrina: Let's swipe our card to get in
Lucia:  说地域笑话
Lucia: That's a regional joke
Katrina:  我今天没带那个夹子
Katrina: I didn't bring the clip today
Katrina:  全国
Katrina: Nationwide
Katrina:  我也不知道
Katrina: I don't know either
Katrina:  随便走吧
Katrina: Let's just walk around
其他人：我记得逛公园有个顺序是这样逆时针还是顺时针我忘了
Others: I remember there's a sequence for walking in the park, is it counterclockwise or clockwise? I forgot
其他人：我忘了
Others: I forgot
Katrina:  哇这还有这还有墓呢
Katrina:  那搁这吧
Katrina: Let's leave it here then
其他人：我们去母婴室
Others: Let's go to the mother and baby room
Katrina:  哇这花好大呀
Katrina: Wow, this flower is so big
Katrina:  这是什么花这么大
Katrina: What kind of flower is this, so big
Katrina:  活过来了
Katrina: It's alive again
Katrina:  公园20分钟
Katrina: 20 minutes in the park
Shure:  有阳光有时候
Shure: Sometimes there's sunlight
Shure:  跳了
Shure: It jumped
其他人：跳了
Others: It jumped
Katrina:  爽了跳了
Katrina: Jumped with joy
Katrina:  会游泳吗跳
Katrina: Can you swim? Jump
Katrina:  不是说还可以划船吗
Katrina: Didn't they say you could row a boat?
Katrina:  这公园他人呢
Katrina: Where are the people in this park?
Katrina:  随便
Katrina: Whatever
Katrina:  不是吧
Katrina: No way
Katrina:  不是吧好像那里面
Katrina: No way, it seems like it's inside there
Katrina:  喝
Katrina: Drink
Katrina:  不收费应该能喝
Katrina: If it's free, it should be drinkable
Katrina:  嗯水的味道
Katrina: Hmm, the taste of water
Katrina:  就那种公园
Katrina: Just like those parks
Katrina:  一般水质比较好的
Katrina: Usually the water quality is good
Katrina:  就会有这种水的味道
Katrina: It has this kind of water taste
Katrina:  我知道波力海苔
Katrina: I know Polly Seaweed.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahaha
Katrina:  感觉当时分手以后
Katrina: I felt after we broke up
Katrina:  就感觉整个人就重生了
Katrina: It felt like I was reborn.
Katrina:  就是很神奇的那种感觉
Katrina: It was such a magical feeling.
Katrina:  就是第一次体会到那种什么磁场不对
Katrina: It was the first time I felt that kind of bad vibes.
Katrina:  然后你整个人变
Katrina: Then everything changed.
Katrina:  然后就开始玩抽象
Katrina: And I started playing abstract.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha
Katrina:  回归本性了
Katrina: Returned to my true self.
Katrina:  本来其实我初中高中
Katrina: Actually, in middle and high school
Katrina:  我从小学开始就天天跟男生玩
Katrina: I played with boys since elementary school.
Katrina:  我爸妈就从来不管我这种谈恋爱
Katrina: My parents never bothered me about dating.
Katrina:  就是因为他们觉得我根本不会谈恋爱
Katrina: Because they thought I would never date.
Shure: 所以你根本不会谈是吗
Shure: So you don't know how to date at all?
Katrina:  对
Katrina: Right.
Katrina:  因为所有都处成哥们了
Katrina: Because I turned everyone into bros.
Katrina:  哇脏脏的dirt
Katrina: Wow, dirty dirt.
Shure:  喂鱼吧
Shure: Feed the fish.
Shure:  啊我没有那什么
Shure: Ah, I don't have that.
Shure:  让一下那块
Shure: Move over there.
Katrina:  呀哈
Katrina: Yeah
Katrina:  吃这么好吗
Katrina: Eating so well?
Katrina:  给你们尝点达美乐
Katrina: Try some Domino's.
Shure:  老北京鱼咱就得吃老北京
Shure: Old Beijing fish, we have to eat it like old Beijing.
Katrina:  哈哈老北京鱼吃达美乐哈哈哈
Katrina: Haha, Old Beijing fish eating Domino's, hahaha.
Shure:  那叫一个地道
Shure: That's what you call authentic.
其他人：它可以吃鸡肉吗
Others: Can it eat chicken?
Shure: 拍一个呗
Shure: Take a shot.
Katrina:  给你录呢
Katrina: Filming you.
Shure: 录这呢
Shure: Filming this.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina:  他们近视吧
Katrina: Are they nearsighted?
Katrina:  你看不见这么浑浊的水
Katrina: Can't see such murky water?
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Jake: 鼓掌有什么用
Jake: What's the point of clapping?
Jake: 鼓掌有什么用啊
Katrina:  哎有小鱼在吃
Katrina: Hey, there's a little fish eating.
Jake: 鱼鱼鱼它鱼它有耳朵是吗
Jake: Fish, fish, fish, does it have ears?
Katrina:  小
Katrina: Small
Katrina:  应该有吧
Katrina: There should be, right?
Jake: 哦这么个音波是吧
Jake: Oh, it's that kind of sound wave, right?
Katrina:  哎呦很好
Katrina: Oh wow, very nice.
Katrina:  这个抛的很准
Katrina: This throw was really accurate.
Shure:  这素材够用吧
Shure: Is this footage enough?
Katrina:  yes
Katrina: Yes.
Katrina:  这老北京鱼吃达美乐呀
Katrina: This old Beijing fish is eating Domino's.
Shure:  全吞了
Shure: Swallowed it whole.
Shure:  那叫一个
Shure: That's what you call...
Katrina:  地道道哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Authentic, hahaha.
Shure:  天嘀嗒地嘀嗒滴答滴滴答
Shure: Tick-tock, tick-tock, tick-tock, tick-tock.
Shure:  滴滴答滴滴答
Shure: Tick-tock, tick-tock.
Katrina:  这鱼
Katrina: This fish...
其他人：在这
Others: It's right here.
Jake: 和鱼一起吃
Jake: Eat it with the fish.
其他人：开始了
Others: It started.
Katrina:  开吃才走两步
Katrina: Just started eating and took two steps.
Jake: 确实很离谱
Jake: It's really ridiculous.
Jake: 这个数据确实
Jake: These numbers are really...
Jake: 不知道为什么能看成这个样子
Jake: I don't know how they can look like this.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈闻所未闻哈
Jake: Hahaha, I've never heard of it, hahaha.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure:  我们如果太偏离人类的正常情况的话
Shure: If we deviate too much from normal human conditions...
Jake: 哈哈好挺好的
Jake: Haha, it's pretty good.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Lucia:  AI应该知道人类并不一直是理性人
Lucia: AI should know that humans are not always rational beings.
Shure:  会污染
Shure: It will pollute.
Katrina:  啊人类
Katrina: Ah, humans...
Jake: 是是是你也很特殊
Jake: Yes, yes, you are also very special.
Katrina:  这就是AI永远无法取取代人类的原因
Katrina: This is why AI can never replace humans.
Jake: 对哎呀不好意思不好意思
Jake: Yes, oh, sorry, sorry.
Lucia:  虽然我知道
Lucia: Although I know...
Lucia:  经济学家也老假设人类是理性人
Lucia: Economists always assume humans are rational beings.
Katrina:  因为人类总会做一些莫名其妙的行为
Katrina: Because humans always do inexplicable things.
Katrina:  这就是人类
Katrina: That's just humans.
Jake: 局部是有逻辑的好吧
Jake: It's logical in parts, alright.
Alice:AI无法理解的
Alice: Which AI can't understand.
Jake: 局部上是有
Jake: It's logical in parts.
Jake: 就是你扔出去
Jake: When you throw it out...
Alice:超多小小小小小鱼苗
Alice: So many tiny tiny tiny baby fish.
Jake: 然后鱼吃披萨
Jake: And then fish eating pizza.
Lucia:  嗯啊那么小的也有竟然
Lucia: Hmm, even such small ones exist.
Jake: 对这个是合理的
Jake: Yeah, that's reasonable.
Jake: 然后你看到鱼扔披萨
Jake: And then you see the fish throwing pizza.
Alice:对就超级超级小的
Alice: Yeah, they are super super small.
Jake: 这个多少是有一点点逻辑了
Katrina:  yes
Katrina: Yes.
Jake: 虽然不多
Jake: Though not by much.
Katrina:  哇哦
Katrina: Wow.
Jake: 这些鱼应该什么都吃
Jake: These fish should eat everything.
Jake: 公园里的鱼都是杂食类的鱼
Jake: The fish in the park are all omnivores.
Jake: 鱼肉会吃吗
Jake: Do they eat fish meat?
Jake: 有应该会
Jake: They probably do.
Lucia: 妈呀
Lucia: Oh my god.
Jake: 应该他们会互相吃
Jake: They probably eat each other.
Shure:  废话我们刚刚看了那个
Shure: Obviously, we just saw that.
Lucia:  大鱼吃小鱼是吧
Lucia: Big fish eat small fish, right?
Jake: 嗯对
Jake: Yeah, right.
Shure:  发现海里鱼都是在吃自己的同类
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Shure:  然后评论难道猪能在海里吗哈哈哈
Shure: And then someone commented, can pigs live in the sea? Haha.
Katrina:  哈哈在海里的不都鱼吗哈哈哈
Katrina: Haha, aren't all the creatures in the sea just fish? Haha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia:  哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice:颐和园的大雁都还挑食呢
Alice: Even the geese in the Summer Palace are picky eaters.
Jake: 这都吃完了
Jake: They ate all of this.
Jake: 哈哈哈这都吃完了这个
Jake: Haha, they ate all of this.
Alice:什么都吃
Alice: They'll eat anything.
Shure:  啊拿多累啊
Shure: Ugh, carrying this is tiring.
Lucia:  还有一块呢
Lucia: There's still a piece left.
Tasha:  在湖边喂喂鱼
Tasha: Feeding fish by the lake.
Jake: 喂人喂鱼
Jake: Feeding people, feeding fish.
Shure:  外边外边
Shure: Outside, outside.
Shure:  自己画的
Shure: I drew it myself.
Katrina:  那我把这块吃了
Katrina: Then I'll eat this piece.
Jake: 对啊一会要有海鸥怎么办
Jake: Yeah, what if a seagull comes?
Katrina:  这一块什么味道
Katrina: What's the flavor of this piece?
Jake: 还有东西喂吗
Jake: Is there anything left to feed?
Katrina:  反正没吃
Katrina: Anyway, nobody ate it.
Tasha:  麦当劳整点薯条
Tasha: Let's get some fries from McDonald's.
Lucia:  盒子里还有点渣
Lucia: There's some crumbs left in the box.
Jake: 还有还有
Jake: There's more, there's more.
Jake: 鱼还有点渣
Jake: The fish has some crumbs too.
Alice:海鸥找点薯条喂他
Alice: Let's find some fries to feed the seagulls.
Lucia:  去码头整点薯条
Lucia: Let's get some fries at the pier.
Jake: 还有点鸡肉
Jake: There's some chicken left.
Jake: 可以给他留着
Jake: We can save it for him.
Jake: 这个可以扔一下哦还
Jake: We can throw this away too.
Jake: 有一盒好
Jake: There's one good box.
Lucia:  啊哈哈哈哈抛洒
Lucia: Hahaha, scatter it around.
Lucia:  哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha
Jake: 骨灰哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Ashes, hahahahahaha
Katrina:  好爽啊
Katrina: So satisfying!
Lucia:  披萨也可以算是种面子的骨灰是吧
Lucia: Pizza can also be considered a type of ashes, right?
其他人：这算一种码头啊
Everyone: This is kind of a pier.
Jake: 对小码头
Jake: Yeah, a small pier.
Jake: 这叫什么湖啊
Jake: What's this lake called?
Jake: 有名字吗
Jake: Does it have a name?
Katrina: 未名湖
Katrina: Weiming Lake.
Alice:未名湖
Alice: Weiming Lake.
Lucia:  未名湖
Lucia: Weiming Lake.
Jake: 好哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Okay, hahahahaha
Lucia:  哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahaha
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha
Katrina:  AI又疑惑了哈哈
Katrina: The AI is confused again, haha.
Tasha:  难道是我扔的不够远吗
Tasha: Did I not throw it far enough?
Katrina:  别抢了别打了
Katrina: Stop fighting!
Katrina:  大家遵守
Katrina: Everyone follow the rules.
Jake: 这边可以预测哪只鱼可以吃得到
Jake: We can predict which fish will get to eat.
Tasha:  哈哈你看我的在那后面就不是吃
Tasha: Haha, look, mine is over there, it's not eating.
Lucia:  这么神奇
Lucia: So amazing.
Katrina:  关键抛物线
Katrina: It's all about the trajectory.
Tasha:  必须要抢才行
Tasha: You have to fight for it.
Katrina:  示范一下
Katrina: Show us.
Katrina:  落点位置
Katrina: The landing spot.
Shure:  你想往哪我就能过了
Shure: Wherever you want, I'll get there.
Shure:  看那边去了
Katrina:  嗯那个塑料哎
Katrina:  问一下AI那是活的
Shure:  那是活的吗
Katrina:  那塑料袋吧
Jake: 啊还有死的呀
Shure:  那塑料袋还是鱼啊
Katrina:  嗯
Lucia:  那是鱼吧
Jake: 那那个
Jake: 就那飘着的吗
Katrina:  嗯
Jake: 哎呦我去
Katrina:  哎我去
Shure:  看好了
Jake: 试试
Alice:哎什么掉了
Katrina:  手串
Tasha:  东西掉了
Lucia:  没有是鱼
Katrina:  手串吗
Katrina: Bracelet?
Shure:  啊
Shure: Huh?
Tasha:  他的手链断了
Tasha: His bracelet broke.
Alice:真的假的
Alice: Really?
Katrina:  完了被女朋友骂死
Katrina: Oh no, his girlfriend will be so mad.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Huh?
Jake: 掉哪去了
Jake: Where did it fall?
Tasha:  掉到湖里了
Tasha: Into the lake.
Alice:未名湖里
Alice: In Weiming Lake.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Huh?
Jake: 掉未名湖了
Jake: It fell into Weiming Lake?
Tasha:  记录下来了
Tasha: It's recorded.
Katrina:  我的眼镜应该看到了
Katrina: My glasses should have seen it.
Jake: 你自己也记了
Jake: You recorded it yourself too?
Shure:  没救了
Shure: It's hopeless.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina:  滑动摩擦力太小了
Katrina: The sliding friction was too low.
Alice:好像也不是很深
Alice: Doesn't seem very deep though.
Alice:要不提供点珍贵素材
Alice: How about we provide some valuable footage?
Lucia:  人类早期下水捕鱼素材
Lucia: Early humans fishing footage.
Jake: 可以
Jake: Okay.
Tasha:  嘿
Tasha: Hey.
Shure:  那怎么还就剩鱼头了呢
Shure: So why is there only a fish head left?
Tasha:  我靠
Tasha: Damn.
Jake: 呃应该是被吃了嗯
Jake: Uh, it must've been eaten, yeah.
Tasha:  应该是被大鱼吃小鱼的时候吃掉了
Tasha: It was probably eaten by a bigger fish.
Tasha:  那头鱼不喜欢吃鱼头
Tasha: The big fish doesn't like eating fish heads.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice:他应该吃鱼身子吧
Alice: It probably eats the body.
Alice:他不吃鱼头
Alice: It doesn't eat the head.
Jake: 是鱼头没什么肉不好吃
Jake: Fish heads don't have much meat, not tasty.
Katrina:  准备好回去下跪吧搓衣板
Katrina: Get ready to kneel on the washboard when you get back.
Jake: 或者是别的一些生物
Jake: Or maybe some other creatures.
Jake: NPU那边有水獭
Jake: There are otters at NPU.
Jake: 水獭吃鱼
Jake: Otters eat fish.
Katrina:  啊
Katrina: Ah.
Lucia:  有什么奇怪景象吗
Lucia: Any strange sightings?
Jake: 吃一半就丢路边
Jake: Eat half and throw it by the road.
Lucia:  让我的让我的眼镜也看一看哈哈
Lucia: Let my glasses see it too, haha.
Tasha:  哎有一头牛奶鱼
Tasha: Hey, there's a milkfish.
Alice:你看那看见没
Alice: Look, see that?
Alice:鱼面已经泡发白了
Alice: The fish face is already bloated white.
Katrina:  你也蛮抽象啊你也蛮抽象
Katrina: You're quite abstract, you know.
Lucia:  好可怕
Lucia: So scary.
Alice:你要捞一下吗
Alice: Do you want to scoop it out?
Lucia:  好可怕
Lucia: So scary.
Alice:找个棍上哪捞去啊
Alice: Find a stick, where to scoop it from?
Katrina:  然后是
Katrina: Then...
Shure: 上哪捞去啊
Alice:大概在哪个位置呢
Alice: Around which area?
Alice:这一片吧
Alice: This area, right?
Jake: 你问问问问有没有那大网子是吧
Jake: Ask if there’s a big net, right?
Shure: 不用捞了
Shure: No need to scoop it out.
Jake: 在哪啊沉进去了
Jake: Where is it? It's sunk.
Tasha:  在那
Tasha: Over there.
Jake: 那一片是吧
Jake: That area, right?
Tasha:  嗯
Tasha: Yep.
Jake: 嗯吼
Jake: Uh huh.
Jake: 跟鱼头在一块差不多
Jake: It's near the fish head.
Jake: 去下一个景点
Jake: Let's go to the next spot.
Jake: 这是什么景点
Jake: What's this place?
Tasha:  湖边喂鱼景点
Tasha: It's the lake where we feed the fish.
Jake: 这叫什么
Jake: What's it called?
Shure:  差不多
Shure: Pretty much.
Tasha:  要一个清水平台区吧
Tasha: We need a clear water platform area, right?
Tasha:  下一个区
Tasha: Next area.
Tasha:  把这一个
Tasha: Take this one.
Tasha:  然后掉掉成项链
Tasha: Then make it into a necklace.
Katrina:  真的吗那是散开了
Katrina: Really? It's scattered.
Katrina:  我以为是直接这样子出去了
Katrina: I thought it just went out like that.
Katrina:  那是散开了
Katrina: But it scattered.
Shure: 散开了
Shure: It scattered.
其他人：当时应应该爆开了
Others: It should have exploded at that moment.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure:  应该是我这个东西他他压的
Shure: It was probably this thing, he pressed it down.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Katrina:  我当时特别害怕你把眼镜甩出去了
Katrina: I was so scared you'd throw your glasses away.
Katrina:  我说完了
Katrina: I was like, it's over.
Alice:看来捞不出来了
Alice: Seems like we can't get it back.
Alice:他竟然散的话只剩珠子吧里面
Alice: If it's scattered, there should only be beads left inside.
Katrina:  那这一个串一下戴
Katrina: Then string this together and wear it.
Katrina:  戴成项链吗
Katrina: Wear it as a necklace?
Katrina:  我心永在
Katrina: My heart will always be with you.
Katrina:  节哀
Katrina: My condolences.
Alice:我帮你提着吧
Alice: Let me hold it for you.
Shure:  让我这个美丽的下午突然不美丽了
Shure: This beautiful afternoon just became not beautiful.
其他人：你今天穿的好那种森系的感觉
Others: You're dressed so much like the forest style today.
其他人：森系
Others: Forest style.
其他人：有点像无印良品的那种风格
Others: A bit like Muji style.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Alice:其实我平时穿衣服都是嗯花里胡哨的
Alice: Actually, I usually dress in a very flashy way.
其他人：哦是吗
Others: Oh, really?
Alice:就是一一个身上可能有五六颜色那种
Alice: Like, I might have five or six colors on me.
Shure:  咱们去的就是这边吧应该这个公园
Shure: The place we're going is this park, right?
Alice:这是我为数不多的浅色衣服
Alice: This is one of the few light-colored clothes I have.
Katrina: 好像不是啊
Katrina: Seems like it's not.
Shure:  他们像被反噬了一样
Shure: They look like they've been counterattacked.
Shure:  然后那个面包喂鱼嘛
Shure: And then, feeding the fish with the bread, right?
Shure:  然后手就突然就崩开了
Shure: Then my hand suddenly just snapped open.
Shure:  好全掉到湖里
Shure: Everything fell into the lake.
Shure:  只有一个掉在外面
Shure: Only one fell outside.
Alice:你你是在快毕业年级吗
Alice: Are you in your final year?
其他人：我是研一
Others: I'm in my first year of grad school.
Alice:研究生了
Alice: Graduate student already.
其他人：我看你们还有要给小狗
Others: I see you guys have something for the puppy.
Alice:这里面吗
Alice: Is it in here?